that's prime minister Mark Ruta has
apologized for his country's historical
role in slavery calling it a crime
against humanity for 250 years hundreds
of thousands of people from Africa and
Asia were enslaved and sold by Dutch
merchants
the Dutch had an extensive Colonial
Empire including at different times
areas in Southeast Asia Africa and of
course the Americas the slave labor was
used throughout its colonies and the
proceeds from the slave trade helped
fund the country's 17th century golden
age
now government ministers are visiting
seven former colonies in the Caribbean
and South America today prime minister
Margarita gave a speech on slavery in
the Hague it's just the latest step in a
long and heated debate over the colonial
past of Netherlands and its role in
slavery reminders of this chapter in the
country's history are easy to find
when Jennifer Tosh walks through
Amsterdam she sees her history on the
walls she's a direct descendant of
people enslaved by the Dutch now she
takes people on walks to show them the
past that is hiding in plain sight well
it's everywhere I mean where we're
standing right now is at the heart of
what's referred to as the golden bend
the wealthiest part of the city where
the founders of the Dutch East and West
India Company and Society of Suriname
where they lived they had their Mansions
here people like Tosh whose families
come from enslaved people have spent
decades pushing for an official apology
for the past and the Damage it did the
fact that the Dutch only had a small
share of the transatlantic slave trade
should not matter she says the Dutch
have centered themselves so much as
exceptional not like the British not
like the French not like the Portuguese
it's given this impression that well we
weren't so bad we only had five percent
compared to world history that's not
that much and it wasn't here it was
always somewhere else out of out of
sight out of mind that sort of nostalgic
way of romanticizing History has left
people thinking well what's all this
fuss about reparations the Netherlands
was among the last countries in Europe
to abolish slavery before they did it's
thought the Dutch enslaved more than
half a million people historian Pepin
Brendan thinks the impact of this
remains
slavery could not exist without a
motivation
why it was that white Europeans could
not be enslaved but black Africans could
be right so there is a foundation of
racism uh there that has its its uh long
Legacy that we still live with
Dutch black lives matter protests in
2020 held shine a light on that racism
an official apology would be a good move
forward says Tosh
it is an important step in the process
but we can't stop there in terms of
education and real societal
understanding Josh says the journey has
just begun
well DW special correspondent Aya
Ibrahim is in The Hague and following
the prime minister's speech uh could you
tell us more about the tone of the
speech today
his tone his one message out of the
speech today here in The Hague was this
is just the beginning of a conversation
uh the Prime Minister acknowledged that
you know the process that led up to this
day has not been easy that it's been
fraught with challenges and that it
could have in fact gone better this is
clearly an allusion to the fact that in
you know in the run-up to this apology
there have been some controversies
especially with uh descendants of the
formerly enslaved who say that they were
not consulted sufficiently there was in
fact even a a court case an attempt to
buy some communities of uh of the
descendants of the formerly enslaved to
you know get this apology canceled or or
stopped so it was definitely the tone
was
um this is just the beginning of the
conversation he said this is not a full
stop this is a comma he also you know
spoke directly to you know the Dutch
people and said even I had you know at
times struggled with understanding how
we could take responsibility for a crime
a historical crime like slavery so
definitely that of continuation and also
trying to appeal to the Dutch public to
to Rally behind this apology
you spoke to a little bit Aya there was
a long debate about how to go about this
official apology why was that so hard
I think this is a common theme when it
comes to Western European country
to apologize for these atrocities
there's always the question well what
next what are we going to do for the
communities that are affected by this
and the key word here really is
reparations are Western European
countries really willing to compensate
the communities that are affected with
uh money a lot of them still suffer from
systemic poverty I think it's also you
know
um this is an issue that is you know
exploited oftentimes uh used by the
right wing in Europe uh it's been
accused of being a wokest trend a topic
that just follows a certain Trend so
certainly it's not been easy getting a
unified message on this
yeah now it's only just happened but how
are the slaves descendants taking this
gesture taking this apology
[Music]
that we have to spoke up so that they
welcomed this certainly but it's a good
first step but as I mentioned there's
always the question of well how does
this affect me how does this affect my
community so far the messaging from the
Dutch government has really been let's
try to you know shed light on this
history a lot of projects are set to be
um you know announced here in the
Netherlands but with communities really
in these former colleges the question is
how does this really benefit us and so
far the Dutch government has not really
given a concrete answer to that other
than dialogue and cultural projects that
are yet to be concretely announced DW
special correspondent I Abraham in the
hike thanks so much